many industries are struggling with a
worker shortage businesses large and
small are all on the hunt for workers
from mega retailers to mom and pop shops
as companies begin staffing up for the
holiday season many say a nationwide
labor shortage is increasingly a
challenge for their businesses it's
probably the tightest labor market we've
ever seen there are sort of plenty of
seasonal positions way more openings
right now than there are job seekers to
lure workers away from the competition
in a year of mass resignations and
stepped-up labor organizing companies
are sweetening their hiring packages
this is the employment cost index a
metric that measures worker compensation
this summer it rose 1.3 percent in the
third quarter from the second the
fastest jump since at least 2001.
costco raised its minimum u.s wage to 17
an hour
amazon which is looking to hire 150 000
seasonal staff is offering bonuses of up
to three thousand dollars in certain
areas
companies are also getting creative with
incentives especially when it comes to
the application process many companies
for years have had sort of in-depth
applications where it might have asked
for extended employment history or
educational background many companies
have said that they've looked at their
applications and stripped out anything
that isn't absolutely relevant either
for government requirements or their own
background check requirements
[Music]
to encourage more applicants to apply
the cosmetic skin care and perfume
company the body shop is eliminating not
just education requirements but also
drug tests background checks and
expectations for a minimum level of
experience
southwest airlines which recently had to
cut flights because of its staffing
shortage is now making on-the-spot job
offers after long shunning the practice
last month the company reversed its
earlier position requiring vaccinations
for employees after aviation unions push
back against the rule raising the
possibility of holiday service problems
southwest says it now plans to allow
employees with approved medical or
religious reasons for avoiding
vaccinations to continue working
[Music]
one of the biggest companies staffing up
this holiday season is the united parcel
service or ups which said it's looking
to hire more than 100 000 people
record-breaking levels of packages are
expected this year shipping companies
like fedex and ups are frantically
searching for help right now we are
looking to hire
drivers both tractor trailer drivers and
local delivery drivers
we're also looking to hire part-time
package handlers and that would be the
largest number of people we're looking
for
to help attract those seasonal workers
ups streamlined its application process
so the company now responds to
applicants with offers within 30 minutes
of submitting the application
in the past applicants wouldn't hear
back from ups for about two weeks it's
been extremely successful in fact
they
survey all of our applicants and they
ask them how the process was
and the numbers went through the roof in
terms of positive
feelings about that whole process they
pivoted towards a digital approach to
hiring people
70 or more of all of our hires are done
on a cell phone
and we were nowhere near that three
years ago ups has also revamped its
outreach strategy to potential employees
we're trying to find people where they
live we're trying to find people where
they spend their time well that's these
days that's on social media between 70
and 75 percent
of our advertising spend
today is done on those social channels
versus
about five years ago when 70
to 75 was done on traditional channels
like print
and broadcast advertising
so it's a complete
flip-flop if you will of where we're
spending our money and how we're trying
to reach people
after the financial crisis of 2007 and
2008 led to a rapid increase in
unemployment many employers had their
pick of qualified job candidates so
after the great recession many employers
inflated the requirements needed for
jobs asking for example for bachelor's
degrees for it help desk specialists or
construction supervisors jobs that were
historically held by high school
graduates
this this left many non-degree holders
with few options besides low-paid
service jobs that didn't offer as much
career or wage growth
but today this decade plus period of
qualification inflation is beginning to
reverse as employers emphasize speed
over credentials to adapt to a
historically tight job market
last year 1.5 million jobs were closed
to people without a college degree but
since then the percentage of employers
that require a college degree dropped
from just over 20 percent in january
2019 to about 15 this october
many workforce specialists and employers
have said that those requirements often
weren't necessary some companies have
looked for example whether asking about
gpa has any impact on their performance
and many have found that it doesn't
economists say that these changes could
also narrow the gap between the 2.5
unemployment rate of college graduates
and the 5.8 rate of job seekers with a
high school diploma so right now there's
a change afoot there's a movement
towards more skill-based hiring looking
at potential rather than degrees and
many economists say this could outlast
the current hiring emergency many think
we'll see more of a movement towards
looking at skills rather than someone's
past experience or degrees
[Music]